Robin I think you said that you never
lived anywhere for more than a few years
growing up and I'm wondering I know your
parents are also artists or actors but
how does that experience of moving
around shaped you did you have to become
a chameleon and how did it make you may
be more confident less confident
whatever it was what did it do
I think moving so frequently really
helps me become more confident because I
I got to shape who it is I wanted to be
if I live somewhere and and you know
kids can be very cruel and but if people
say oh she talks too much or oh she says
her oh she's that in another year or two
I was going to be living somewhere else
and I could dial that down you know and
so I listened to the I listen to what
people's perception of me was I didn't
become anything other than what I wanted
to be and what I believed was the best
person I could be you know I didn't go
and you know try to keep up with the
popular girls in school or buy the
latest shoes or do the latest purse when
you're 14 I mean for God's sake really
it's your parents buying it anyway it
doesn't say who you are just as what
they can afford but but I it allowed me
to to shape myself I wouldn't say be a
chameleon because to me that means you
become you know where you are at that
moment and I didn't do that I was who I
was where I was at any given moment but
who I was was changed over the years by
by paying attention and seeing other
people's behavior and not wanting to be
that seeing how other people's behavior
could hurt others and why would they do
that so that's not a quality to adopt
and it also I think made it really easy
for me as a as an actor because I got to
observe all kinds of people from all
walks of life
and from all over the country and all
over the world actually because when I
was 17 I moved to Europe for a while and
for six months and so you just it
allowed me to see the world in a way
that many many people don't to see that
there were no matter how broke we were
at the time there was somebody less well
off than we were and and I think it
increased my compassion and my
understanding about how the world works
and how people work within it so for
people that are moving here from let's
say a small rural community maybe they
haven't been exposed to other people
except for people that have lived there
for generations right or or something
similar what would you say is a good way
where they could almost have a similar
experience here because I know a lot of
people that have moved from small towns
they're now here and I'm sure it's got
to be culture shock for them even just
the way like drive on the freeways and
just just the busyness of this town how
do they sort of become more at peace
with who they are so they don't have to
become chameleons the first thing I
would say is as hard as it may be
especially in this superficial town
do not ever compare yourself or your
journey to anyone else and their journey
you have no idea what they have been
through what they may be going through
that they themselves I mean in the
future that they themselves aren't even
aware of but maybe fall them so this
town I keep mentioning this but because
the town is so superficial this town
bases a lot on what you wear the table
you get the car you drive your zip code
hell your area code on your phone you
know and I'm a proud 3 2 3 by the way
and don't do that you know the values
that you probably grew up with those of
you who came from a smaller town are
usually pretty good values and hold on
to them and because this town will try
to beat the goodness out of you it will
there
I have recently written the book and and
and there's a chapter in it called the
company you keep
and the subtitle is be where the soul
eaters because you will come here with
your joy and your happiness and somebody
who isn't as joyful or happy as you will
be jealous of that and will try to knock
you down a peg and make you feel that
the little accomplishment that you just
got not that much and they'll throw
their thing that they've just done at
your feet like you know
well yes nice you got that audition but
I just got this job on such-and-such
it's amazing how insecure so many people
here are so beware the soul leaders
those are the ones who you share some
good thing that has just happened to you
and they try to diminish its value and
avoid them like the plague yeah and I
think that's great because I know you
you're all about being positive and your
book is about remaining upbeat and
positive but I think that's an important
part to touch on because I know
especially for me when I came here I
would notice a lot of braggarts and I
remember somebody who'd been here a few
years said sometimes none of that is
even true right
but it's likes you out because you don't
know that when you're writing you think
when these people are telling you this
you believe it am i right they do these
little things and so I think that's
important to talk about because you are
about remaining upbeat and believing in
the good right but there is that element
that I think a lot of people aren't
totally aware of at first you're very
right about that you you know you're
swept along in the in the dream of what
Hollywood can be and what you can be
within it and and you want to be around
the people that are successful but as
you said a lot of people build up build
themselves up in a way that isn't isn't
genuine isn't real and they often do it
in a concerted effort to diminish the
person they're talking to right it's
shocking I mean it is good to me that
people do that but they do and the
sooner the more quickly you can get away
to come aware of that the better and I
think to that
growing up in the theater my folks were
professional actors they weren't famous
but they made their living doing it
growing up in the theater made me
acutely aware of the fact that no
project no matter what business you're
in no project is done exclusively by one
person or by one cohort you know it
takes all of us to make especially a
creative project to make a to write a
play to perform a play to produce a play
or a film or a television show it takes
a lot of people the craft service guy is
just as frickin important as the
executive producer and you're going to
see a lot more of the craft service
person than you do an executive producer
so you have to be kind to everyone
because everyone that you meet in this
and respectful of everyone but you also
have to identify the soul leaders and
avoid them but everyone that you meet in
this business or any other business can
become in essence an agent for your good
for instance that job that first job
that I booked I got because of a cook at
a hamburger stand that I worked for he
sold the hamburger stand he took a few
favorite headshots of me and went to
work at the commissary at Warner
Brothers and handed them out in line to
people going she's an actress she's
fabulous
I have no idea how he knew that because
he never saw me perform anything other
than the act of making change but he
just believed in me and he liked me and
I liked him and I got my first job out
of it and you never know who you're
going to meet who's going to say hey you
know uh you you know she you should know
her I mean honestly if you think about
it someone that you did an interview
with recently is the one who introduced
us true you know so it works all the
time
very true and this and it's wonderful
and it isn't just about being Pollyanna
pie-in-the-sky believing everything will
be good no it's just about realizing
that you're luckier than you think you
are and that you accomplished more than
you think you do because everybody in
this town as I said is trying to beat
that concept out of you that if you
didn't get a major television show
or if you didn't do this that you know
meeting with agents or potential
managers or working on your own show or
something like that is worthless well
it's not it's sustaining it's your job
you